I've got one two three four five six
solutions six solutions I said I was
going to mention this earlier where six
appearing why is six important in this
question because it's this it's the
sixth root okay six now I'm how many of
you do echo here how many echo students
it going to okay all right no man echo
students hopefully when they see key the
letters ft and a they think free trade
agreement okay but in the mathematics
classroom what I think all and you
should all write this down really
important zone it's called the
fundamental you know it's a big deal
when it starts with you in front of
pencil okay the fundamental theorem of
algebra free trade agreements you your
human inventions the fundamental theorem
of algebra is something to build into
numbers what it says is that if you have
a polynomial of degree whatever number
you like let's call it m okay this time
it's six if you've got a polynomial of
degree M you will have exactly n
solutions and complex solutions you can
see a lot of these I'm not going to be
real numbers in fact have a look look
for me we're going to draw this in a
second but can you tell just by looking
at these solutions which one of these
arguments are going to give us a numbers
that are gonna be real can you tell me
which ones they'll be okay 0 that's
going to give us a real number because
in fact that's the obvious solution that
I pointed out before right do you
remember modulus 1 argument 0 so that's
just 1 now 2 pi I'm gonna leave that one
out because I've kind of already
mentioned here 2 pi gives me the same
complex of which other one will give me
a real
every pie right because pie spins me
back onto da the negative side of the
real axis so what you're gonna get every
time is the number of solutions matching
this okay you remember at the very first
lesson I said complex numbers it's us
searching for the building blocks of
like that what's the bottom what are all
the numbers like basically built on when
you get some complex numbers every
quadratic has two solutions every cubic
has three solutions every I don't know
what it is Ruth for variance explained
that's got it why have six solutions if
you've got complex numbers all right
I'm almost done pretty actually I'll
answer the question now the question was
what are the sixth roots I know all of
them have a modulus at one I found all
these different angles now I just have
to state what the roots oh so I'm gonna
run out of space here
therefore the six roots are we're going
to list them and then we're gonna tour
okay so here we go
his n is equal to I'm gonna write all
these in polar form first let's see how
we feel
I can write this as cos 0 plus I sine 0
it's just one you notice that you have
an eye out the front but I don't why
didn't I write it just one does change
the number is the first one what's the
next one cos PI on three plus
you can see you know I sort of flamed it
a little bit I don't like to see
sanitation right but you see why people
appeal to it because it is faster but
cause - by 1/3
and
okay so that's a bit messy but you get
the idea
now I start this lesson with the premise
that graphing stuff is nice for its own
sake but where it's really useful is
where it helps you solve other stuff
okay now where are these guys on the
complex plane what do they look like
draw for me in a complex plane this one
needs to be to me and let's plot these
let's draw them okay because there are
six solutions I'm gonna designate them
they have ones and twos and threes it
forwards at five six six I usually use a
subscript like said six
where are they going to go is it what is
the easy one it's gonna go to zero
silence where would you let me draw this
that's like 60 degrees up that way okay
so I think maybe sit and it's going to
the same distance by the way same
distance away from the origin so maybe
something like that I think that's
that's pretty good I think that's about
climb of three nothing
was it three gonna be the next solution
along he's going to actually go on the
opposite side of the imaginary actives
you notice that there's a symmetry hi
that's suspicious I can keep going I'm
up now to the fourth route and this is
the one which gets me back onto the real
axis
so now that you got a picture for this
you can see if I were to draw this whole
thing out what you've got your sixth
roots of this complex number they all
reside on a circle they're all centered
on the origin and you're also notice
they aren't evenly spaced out do you see
that there's this one over here then you
go pilot or radians clockwise go another
pilot 3 radians clockwise another poem
three another pound three and the last
poem three okay so you can see here
these complex roots right if you're
going to third fourth fifth sixth and
throughs okay you're just going to get
all of these points on the circumference
if you had drawn this circle you could
do that or alternatively a better way of
doing it is that this circle has a name
right it sense it on the origin and its
radius is 1 so this is the is the unit
circle right so I would probably just
mark that is one that is one that is
negative one and that is maybe one and
that is unambiguously all of radius one
so that way you don't have to draw like
say 15 and per radii being labeled that
shows you that's definitely the sir okay
all right now let me make a note I gave
you this bit flowery peace languishing
in the fundamental theorem of algebra
okay
you see a big name like that means it's
important this number here these six
numbers that were just found by the way
they're the roots of wound okay now one
is an important number
just like zero is an important number
zero is so important we give it a name
we call it the origin right wine in the
same way also has a name but no one who
doesn't do extension do doesn't lose
what his name is
we call it unity so if you go into an
extension to textbook you'll find a
hanging that says roots of unity and
this is what they're talking about right
it's all of the roots to whatever degree
of a number one units being one